роками Європа перебувала на гачку Росії
через викопне паливо у 2021 році 40%
газу до ЄС надходили з РФ більше
половини експорту російської нафти
призначалися та Європи а російські шахти
безперервно постачали вугілля для
європейських Тез в цілому у рік перед
вторгненням реф та України Європа
придбала у росіян викопного палива на
100 мільярдів доларів Таким чином стаючи
в залежність від країни-агресора і
фінансуючи його
ще у школі нас завжди вчили не класти
всі яйця в один кошик
це фатіх піроль виконавчий директор
міжнародного енергетичного агентства
організації за участі міністрів
енергетики провідних країн світу
Європа поклала усі яйця в один кошик
кошик зруйнували а яйця розбилися
уже через тиждень після вторгнення
команда бірюля склала план дій з 10
пунктів аби послабити залежність Європи
від російського газу він передбачав
зокрема купівлю газу в інших країн
затримку закриття АС та посили на
виробництво сонячних панелей та вітрових
турбін серед рекомендацій була й більш
брудна опція спалювати більше вугілля та
нафти у своїй сукупності такі дії могли
б удвічі скоротити потребу в російському
газі до кінця 2022 року тоді ж я провів
розмови з лідерами урядів у Європі вони
вважали план занадто радикальним
але попри певну стриманість Євросоюз
взяв на озброєння більшість пропозицій
перше що зробила Європа замінила викопне
паливо з РФ іншим є закупив більше газу
залиширу та Норвегії а також домовився
про поставки зрідженого природного газу
зі США та Катару А ще повернувся до
джерела енергії від якого клявся
відмовитися вугілля немає майбутнього
так запевняв головний представник з
питань клімату на саміті 2021 року тоді
багаті країни залежні від газу зухвало
переконували бідніші відмовитися від
вугілля однак після скорочення Путіним
поставок газу в Європу а станом на
жовтень 22-го майже повної їх зупинки ці
країни почали знову запускати старі
вугільні станції
Утім проблеми полягала в тому що Європа
переживала енергетичну кризу не лише
через Росію
Європа охопила найгірше за десятиліття
посуха шалена посуха Висушила річки
Європи тому ГЕС виробляли менше
електроенергії у Франції головним
джерелом струму залишалася атомна
енергія але місцеві АС потерпали через
проблеми з обслуговуванням погіршували
ситуацію те що Німеччина Та Бельгія саме
були в процесі відмови від виробництва
атомної енергії та зрештою Бельгія
подовшла роботу АС на 10 років а ФРН на
кілька місяців При цьому до кліматичних
цілей Європи належало прагнення якомога
швидше відмовитися від вугілля аж до
цілковитої відмовою У 2030 році
натомість у 2022 в ЄС спалили на 7%
більше вугілля ніж у 2021 але це було
лише першою несподіванкою європейської
енергетичної кризи камбек вугілля стане
таким масштабним як прогнозували в
останньому кварталі 2022
36 вугільних станцій до експлуатації
яких повернулися на випадок крайньої
необхідності працювали лише на 18% своєї
спроможності причому 9 з них взагалі не
використали тож поки Європа спалювала
трохи більше вугілля найбільше торік
зросли потужності вітрової та сонячної
енергетики
сонячна енергія королева енергоринків у
всьому світі і наступниця старого короля
вугілля
Європа не просто перейшла на інше
викопне паливо щоб замінити російський
газ вона прискорила свій перехід на
чисту енергію у 2022 році є становив
більше сонячних панелей та вітрових
турбін збудував більше батареї та
інсталював більше теплових насосів ніж
будь-коли раніше єврокомісія підвищила
свої цілі щодо частки відновлювальної
енергії на 2030 рік 40 до 45%. а також
полегшила умови спорудження необхідної
для цього інфраструктури і все ж
європейські лідери неохоче вдалися до
застосування одного доволі очевидного
важеля зменшення використання енергії у
середньому будівлі Європі опалюється до
температури 22 градуси за Цельсієм це
значно більше ніж потрібно для комфорту
план тіймея вказував на те що зниження
температури хоч на один градус зменшує
потребу в газі на 10 мільярдів
кубометрів однак лише деякі уряди
справді інвестували ресурси в публічній
компанії покликані змінити опалювальні
звички людей
[музика]
поза сумнівом у Європі був більший
потенціал для заощадження газу енергії у
більших обсягах Ми добре впоралися але
якщо ви запитаєте чи на відмінно то я
скажу Ні у
ноу зрештою допомогли дві
речі деякі країни на кшталт Німеччини
знизили температуру громадських будівлях
Франція попросила своїх громадян
опалювати домівки і офіси не більше ніж
до 19 градусів хоч не запровадила
відповідного контролю по-друге ще більше
несподівана підтримка для подолання
кризи надійшла від клімату зима 2022
року стала другою найтеплішою Зимою в
Європі відколи фіксують такі показники
тобто людям просто не довелося багато
опалювати домівки крім того промислові
підприємства скоротили виробництво
застосувавши на 25% газу менше загальна
потреба в ЄС 2022 року впала до 50
мільярдів кубометрів газу найбільше
падіння в історії починаючи з вересня
потреба у струмі була незвично низькою
нам пощастило з теплою Зимою я наголошую
на цьому коли спілкуюся з урядами бо
наступної зими нам не варто знову
розраховувати на удачу і теплу зиму
та на скільки серйозним є перехід Європи
на зелену енергію принаймні можна було
зробити більше аби ще швидше відмовитися
від нафти РФ
верхня цінова межа на російську нафту
набула чинності викликавши Гнів Москви
та додавши викликів нафтовому ринку
санкції запровадили лише в грудні 2022
року тож за минулий рік ЄС імпортував
лише на 16% нафти менше ніж у попередній
рік багато країн запровадили субсидії на
пальне для водіїв замість того щоб
допомогти людям відмовитися від Авто чи
купити електромобіль непокоїть і те
наскільки великі ставки роблять це на
зріджений газ країни як Німеччина в яких
не було інфраструктури для отримання
поставок затвердили будівництво значно
більшої кількості терміналів ніж
необхідно вказують експерти лише
половини і запланованої Європи
інфраструктури для зрідженого газу ще
буде потрібною У 2030 році варто
зауважити що деякі європейські уряди
уклали угоди щодо поставок газу з
країнами на штат катеру на Щонайменше 15
років а це в принципі змушує
засумніватися чи засвоїли вони урок
минулого коли надто покладалися на Росію
коли пил ляжеться урядом Європи включно
з ФРН варто вдатися до самокритики
переглянувши власну енергетичну політику
бо на мій погляд це було стратегічною
помилкою з наслідками не лише для
енергетики а й для зовнішньої політики
врешті-решт вторгнення Путіна в Україну
зумовило переворот в енергетичній
системі ЄС з одного боку це примусило
Євросоюз спалювати більше вугілля та
купувати більше газу Таким чином
завадивши європейцям виконувати власні
кліматичні цілі які вони намагалися
нав'язати іншим водночас оговшись від
шоку Континент позбувся залежності від
енергоносіїв з Росії а це не лише на
короткий час дало поштовх переходу на
відновлювані джерела енергії Це призвело
до глибших структурних змін які
прискорюють перехід на зелену енергію
якщо експерти не помиляються повернення
до вугілля не буде тривалим а от різке
зростання частки чистої енергії вже не
зупинити